nos preguntan que tabla tiene una
constante de proporcionalidad entre x de
0.6 elige una respuesta pausa el vídeo e
inténtalo
bien solo como recordatorio una forma de
pensar en la constante de
proporcionalidad entre y x es que jeff
es igual a k una constante por x jeff es
proporcional a x y esta constante de
aquí es justo nuestra constante de
proporcionalidad por lo tanto si esta
constante es 0.6 entonces la tabla que
contenga una constante de
proporcionalidad de 0.6 deberá cumplir
que quien sea igual a 0.6 por x esto
para cada par xy así que veamos nuestras
opciones
acaso 70.6 veces 4 bueno no 7 es más
grande que 4 de hecho 0.6 x 42.4 por lo
tanto podemos decir que en definitiva
esta tabla no tiene una constante de
proporcionalidad
de 0.6 de hecho esta tabla ni siquiera
tiene una relación proporcional observa
para la primera fila
tuvimos que multiplicar por siete
cuartos para obtener siete y en la
segunda fila tuvimos que multiplicar por
diez sextos que es lo mismo que cinco
tercios esto para obtener 10 y en la
tercera fila
tuvimos que multiplicar por 13 octavos
para obtener 13 y como no estoy
multiplicando por la misma constante en
cada fila podemos concluir que no
tenemos una relación proporcional para
esta primera tabla ahora veamos la
opción b como pasamos de 4 a 2.4 bueno
aquí está estamos multiplicando por 0.6
pero esto no es suficiente para concluir
que
esta tabla es una verdadera relación
proporcional recuerda tenemos que
multiplicar por 0.6 en cada escenario
para que eso se cumpla así que veamos 9
por 0.6
es 5.4 sí perfecto 9 por 6 654 pero esto
es 9 por 0.6 que es 54 entre 10 que es
5.4 y luego tengo 14 por 6 bueno 14 por
6 es 84 por lo tanto 14 por 6 entre 10
en efecto será 8.4
así que si estoy multiplicando por 0.6 y
ya con esto puedo decir que esta es
nuestra opción correcta
sin embargo verifiquemos el inciso para
darnos cuenta de que no es el caso 3
para obtener 2 lo que hicimos fue
multiplicar por dos tercios 9 para
obtener 6 en la segunda fila lo que
hicimos fue multiplicar por dos tercios
y aquí también en la tercera fila lo que
hicimos fue multiplicar por 2
y de hecho aquí tenemos una tabla que
describe una relación proporcional sin
embargo la constante de proporcionalidad
en este caso es de dos tercios que si
intentas expresar lo como un decimal
obtendrás 0.6 periódico por lo tanto
podemos decir que es proporcional pero
no tienen esta constante de
proporcionalidad de 0.6 que buscará por
lo tanto la opción correcta es el inciso
b cancelaremos el inciso c y hemos
acabado nos vemos pronto en el siguiente
vídeo